late last week we reported that gas
prices had hit a whopping
3.73 cents per gallon on average
man those were the good old days you
remember those wonderful old days now
gas is up to four dollars and 17 cents
per gallon that's a 44 cent jump from
last week and a 61 cent spike from a
month ago
one year ago today
after only a month and a half of joe
biden wreaking havoc on the economy gas
averaged just 2.76
per gallon nationally now it's hit an
all-time high so what is joe biden going
to do to fix it
you guessed it absolutely nothing
can't do much right now
russia's responsible
can't do much it's putin's fault
everything is putin's fault the buck
stops with putin
except
gas prices were already spiking under
joe biden well before putin invaded
ukraine
gas has been going up consistently since
just after joe biden was sworn into
office but according to biden that is
purely a coincidence it has nothing to
do with his energy policies
look let me be clear
about two other points first it's simply
not true that my administration or
policies are holding back domestic
energy production
that's simply not true
it's simply not true okay it's simply
not true that biden canceled the
keystone xl pipeline on his first day in
office it's simply not true that biden
re-entered the anti-fossil fuel paris
agreement on his first day in office
it's simply not true that biden
suspended all new federal gas and oil
leases five days after he was sworn into
office it's simply not true
that biden just a couple weeks ago
indefinitely froze decisions about new
federal oil and gas drilling it's simply
not true even though i distinctly
remember all of those things happening
so either my memory is failing me and
all those news reports about all those
well-known policy decisions are an
illusion or
joe biden is lying again and gaslighting
us all again trying to distract from his
uninterrupted record of failure by
claiming that putin ate his homework
who you gonna believe joe biden or your
own lying eyes
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from cool papa j magic
that guy always has the best comments
that guys appeared on this show in the
my favorite comment section probably a
dozen times at this point he writes i'm
just so tired of the lies good news is
gaslighting is about to get a lot more
expensive you are so right it is
everything is getting more expensive
necessarily because of one because when
fuel costs go up all the costs go up and
also joe biden's economy has just seen
record inflation the one good that does
not need to go up in price if you don't
want it to
meat if you're buying it from good
ranchers right now go to
goodranchers.com slash knowles k-n-r-w
l-e-s for my favorite meat
one area that we have seen inflation
really spike recently is in the grocery
store i'm sure that you've seen it it
feels like prices have doubled
except while prices have doubled in the
grocery store good ranchers prices have
stayed low and affordable what's really
amazing too so you can just buy one-off
boxes of meat from good ranchers and i
would recommend it you can get really
great stuff try out lots of different
stuff but if you subscribe
which is in my view the better way to do
it you don't even have to think about it
again you just get that wonderful meat
delivered reliably if you subscribe
your price never goes up so you've got
insane inflation everywhere in the
country and yet your best price for meat
is locked in
for life eighty-five percent of the
grass-fed beef that you get in the
united states it's not really from
the united states it's imported from
overseas you're getting that low quality
stuff instead get that good high-quality
american
meat and lock in your price for life get
a 30 discount on top of all that right
now on prime stakes and better than
organic chicken go to goodranchers.com
knowles to save on the quality you've
been looking for good ranchers takes the
guesswork out of the grocery store by
sourcing everything from local farms and
shipping it to your door use code
knowles k wle s enjoy your box of 100
american meat 30 in savings on top of
that order now to combat inflation with
good ranchers american meat delivered
so
putin did everything everything that has
happened that's bad under joe biden it's
all putin's fault even stuff that
happened before putin invaded ukraine
it's putin forget about it what can i do
nothing it's putin go talk to putin
putin putin ate my homework
that is joe biden's story and he's
sticking to it
now some of the members of his cabinet
they realize that you just you can't
blame every bad thing in the world on
vladimir putin so some people are
offering a different answer if you're
worried about gas prices going up
bootage has a simple solution for you uh
just buy a tesla
clean transportation can bring
significant cost savings for the
american people as well
last month we announced a 5 billion
investment to build out a nationwide
electric vehicle charging network so the
people from rural to suburban to urban
communities can all benefit from the gas
savings of driving an eevee
there are wonderful gas savings guys
plus pretty soon the cars are going to
be self-driving and they've got that
cool imac screen right in front of you
and it's great and when you when you
drive up to uh fun uh parties with all
of your wealthy friends uh you can
compare do i have the model s
oh you have the model x that's a lot
that's the answer right to middle class
families who are struggling to decide do
i fill up the gas tank or do i
buy clothes for my children we played a
woman in michigan just a few days ago
who said now when she buys clothes for
her children she's got to decide what is
she going to prioritize well it's very
simple you just buy a tesla right
so tone deaf this is the problem with
pete pete's a pretty good politician
in the sense that he went from total
obscurity
he was the mayor of a very small town in
indiana to a cabinet secretary
so he's a very good political careerist
but he's not great in terms of
connecting with people the only election
he's ever won is from his very small
town
so when when he says these things you
see a lot of of
his his privilege for lack of a better
word coming out this is a guy who spent
his whole life in a university bubble
that's where he grew up because his dad
was a very well-known
marxist scholar actually
his dad is one of the best-known
scholars of the father of what's called
cultural marxism antonio gramsci so he
grew up in that sort of ivory tower
setting and then he went off to harvard
and then he went off to mckinsey right
so he's been in isis what what's what's
wrong with you just go buy a tesla then
you don't need to worry about gas prices
at all it's not just pete budage stephen
colbert making the very same point
russia has been hit with a series of
crippling sanctions and it looks like
there's more to come because the u.s and
its european allies are now discussing
banning imports of russian oil take that
putin we're not gonna buy our gas from a
war criminal we're gonna buy it from the
good guys saudi arabia
but
it's gonna cost
since the invasion oil prices have
skyrocketed today the average gas price
in america hit an all-time record high
of over four dollars per gallon okay
that stings but a clean conscience is
worth a buck or two
i'm willing to pay
it's important right
it's important i'm willing to pay four
dollars a gallon hell i'll pay 15
a gallon because i drive a tesla
this is such a telling joke
in every joke there is a little element
of truth and here i think there's a big
element of truth the joke is i don't
care what gas prices are you know gas
prices if they go up it just shows that
i care about freedom in ukraine that i'm
sticking it to vladimir putin i don't
care if they go up to a hundred dollars
a gallon because it doesn't affect me
because i don't even put gas in my car
yeah and so that's that's the joke
except that's the reality too there's
something else really interesting about
this clip as a result of of our ban on
russian oil america is now looking to
increase oil supplies from saudi arabia
sure but also iran and venezuela
and in the joke here colbert says oh wow
we're going from one really bad guy to
another really bad guy and the other bad
guy he points to is saudi arabia which
is actually an ally of the united states
he doesn't say oh great we're going from
russian oil to iran
because the libs love iran even though
iran is the largest state sponsor of
terror in the world the libs are super
into iran they were pushing for a
ridiculous iran deal that would have
given iran a nuclear weapon they're
pushing for that again venezuela they
love the socialist government in
venezuela they've been talking up the
socialist government in venezuela for 20
years now they've been talking it up
since the days of hugo chavez they still
like this guy nicholas maduro a
socialist dictator down there so he
won't even make that joke he won't even
make the joke oh now we've got to deal
with socialist dictators or the crazy
ayatollah and the mullahs who are
funding terror around the world no
because they like those guys too much
they only go after saudi arabia but then
he comes to his point he says look i
don't care if it's 15 a gallon because i
drive a tesla
what you're seeing here
even in this little joke
is the perversion of our system of law
from
a
care for the common good
into a care purely for self-interest
what is the law
seems like a simple question and yet i
bet a lot of people cannot answer it
thomas aquinas gives a very simple
definition of what the law is
the law is an ordinance of reason for
the common good
made by him who has care of the
community and promulgated that's it very
simple
an ordinance of reason for the common
good of the whole community law is not
just how to benefit some people at the
expense of other people in the community
it's actually for the common good
made by the person who has charge of the
care of the community the authority who
has care of the community
and then promulgated declared publicly
and followed by all
but that's not how the libs view law
anymore
the way the libs view law is that
there's one set of rules for them and
another set of rules for everyone else
the way the libs view the law is that
the law is a a way
to
gain
the advantage for certain interest
groups
and this is not me denigrating the left
this is how they openly speak of the law
that that the law and politics is not a
matter of civilized reasoned debate
where we persuade our fellow citizens of
what is good for all of us the true
common good not just the
amalgamation of all of our individual
interests lumped together but the actual
common good that serves everyone that
leads to a flourishing republic what is
a republic it means the things we all
hold in common
no they don't view it that way they say
well the law is a way for this
marginalized group to finally stick it
to that other marginalized group they
view it as sort of the opposite of a
common good yeah raise those gas prices
that'll stick it to those rube idiot
conservatives who are polluting our
environment and it won't affect me
because i've got my tesla yeah let's
shut down the economy and shut down all
of the stores for
not just months but years at a time
because i've got my laptop lifestyle it
doesn't matter i can just do work in my
nice apartment in new york and oh the
working class the blue collar worker who
can't get his paycheck anymore well too
bad whoopsie daisy that'll show him
maybe he should be a little bit more
like me
two views of the law one not so great a
lot of downsides to that view of law and
politics and community
when you want an upside i would strongly
recommend you go check out get upside
gas has just hit an all-time high if you
do not download the free get upside app
right now and get cash back every time
you fill up your tank
i don't know what to do with you i can't
talk to you you are not open to reason
and logic okay just download the free
get upside app today use promo code
knowles you will get 25 cents per gallon
or more on your first fill up cash back
by the way it's not just at the gas pump
anymore
you'll also get up to 30 cash back at
grocery stores at restaurants food
delivery as well there's no catch here
just cash back it's very simple the cash
back gets sent to your bank account to
your paypal if you prefer to an amazon
gift card it's very easy to get the cash
back it's free you just download the
free
get upside app use promo code knowles
k-n-o-w-l-e-s
get 25 cents per gallon or more cash
back on your first tank use that code
right now knowles canadaw l-e-s that is
k-n-o-w l-e-s
speaking of the law and the common good
we've got an update from criminal
justice reform you know i try to do this
at least once a week sometimes i've got
to do it every single day
this is an update from all the wonderful
compassionate criminal justice reform
that that helps those poor oppressed
criminals get out of jail and get back
on the street what are they doing oh
they're assaulting people all the time
headline from the daily wire career new
york city criminal assaults two people
in a week walks free because of new
york's lacks bail reform laws so there's
a guy
this guy has
20 arrests
since 1999
this week
he was arrested
just this past week he was arrested he
was arrested and released
twice
for two separate assaults thanks to new
york's wonderful criminal justice reform
laws
37 year old dude
was arrested after allegedly assaulting
a woman on the new york subway in late
february
the surveillance video from the bronx
shows this guy walk up to a woman with a
plastic bag in his hand
then without saying a word he smashed
the contents of the bag which apparently
was his own feces
into her face then smeared it on the
back of her head and then ran away
why did he do this well because he went
up and made a pass at her i guess he was
sort of sexually assaulting her and then
she was not interested in him so he went
into the car defecated came back smeared
it on her face
now call me old-fashioned
but i think that when fellas do that
sort of thing
they ought to go to jail
and stay in jail and not be released
immediately
i guess i'm just an old knuckle-dragging
conservative because all the the bail
reform abolished prisons defund the
police grad they believe that it's a
good thing to have more people on the
street
rubbing bags of their own fecal matter
into the faces of innocent bystanders
he was arrested at a homeless shelter
on monday where he joked about the
incident he was asked about it were you
responsible for this he said and he said
to the cops [ __ ] happens ha ha this is
an shi tty situation
so by the way he's not just completely
crazy sometimes
one of the causes of of homelessness
especially in new york but really
everywhere is mental illness
so some of these guys they're doing
things they have no idea what they're
doing they're just totally out of their
minds this guy's not totally out of his
mind
he's aware of it he's making puns about
the situation
then
during his arraignment he said he was
being mistreated by the system
shouted insults at the judge
and then
he was freed without bail
because that's the way new york operates
now because of that bail reform law he
also by the way he had been
arrested
a little further back because he was
walking around crown heights chasing
down jews screaming
effing jews i'm going to kill you
then he spat on a guy's chest tried to
punch him missed ran away
he does this all the time he's a career
criminal
that's that is what criminal justice
reform is that is what bail reform is
that is what when we talk about
over-incarceration that's exactly what
we're talking about and the libs and the
squishes i'm sorry to say and by the way
even some
relatively conservative republicans for
goodness sakes even trump during the
trump administration trump took up this
cause of
criminal justice reform over
incarceration we're going to let
we're going to let the criminals out of
out of jail
that's not our problem our problem is
not that we have too many criminals in
jail our problem is that we have far too
few criminals in jail and women are
being sexually harassed and having feces
rubbed on their face because of it and
then even after that happens the
criminals get off the hook they're
released and you know what they're going
to do they're going to do it again right
away
this is one of those issues
where somehow the ruling class
is living on a completely different
planet the vast majority of people
in both parties
think that there is too much crime and
we need to get tougher on crime
and yet the politicians
mostly democrats but some republicans
too
they say oh you know what you know what
our problem is we don't have enough
crime let's let those criminals back on
the street the democrats are waking up
to this
they realize that
we've got midterm elections coming up
this is not playing very well in peoria
and so they're trying to run away from
the fact that they have supported
defunding the police abolishing the
police for years now you're hearing this
from top democrats in congress
top democrats and party leadership they
are saying look these republicans
they're lying this is fake news they're
spreading misinformation we do not
support defunding the police we've never
supported defunding the police oh yeah
roll the tape
progressives on capitol hill are echoing
the chance heard from protesters on
streets in major cities around the
country congresswoman elon omar whose
district includes minneapolis has called
the police there rotten to the route
saying the department shouldn't just be
defunded it should be dismantled we mean
ending this department as it currently
exists i am for defunding the police
some city officials calling for police
departments across the u.s to be
defunded proceeded to leave tweeting no
more policing incarceration and
militarization it can't be reformed what
we've seen in los angeles mayor eric
garcetti saying take some of the money
from policing about 150 million dollars
invested in health initiatives training
initiatives for youth i applaud eric
garcetti for doing what he's done
painted in huge block letters on city
streets from washington to wisconsin
some who support the idea want to strip
all police funding and dissolve entire
departments there's some issues that we
ask police to do like mental health
issues or policing in schools and all
the rest that perhaps we can
shuffle some of that money around we
don't want no more police but we need to
completely dismantle the minneapolis
police department yes i support the
defund movement
so it's not just some no-name wacky
eccentric
liberal columnist
it's not even some backbencher liberal
democrat
members of congress
it's not even just the squad although
you just heard i think the entire squad
there
i'm not i don't i didn't hear if rashida
talib was in that clip she's called for
this too though rashida talib actually
called for the complete dismantling of
the entire federal prison system
just gone no more federal prisons
whatsoever
but but it's not even just them it's not
even just aoc and talib and ayanna
presley and bilhan omar
it's nancy pelosi
it's kamala harris
the vice president of the united states
these people all called
to
varying degrees for defunding the police
and now we've got a massive crime spike
going around and they are running away
they are trying to gaslight you they're
saying no this had nothing to do with us
la la la
fake news this is just republicans lying
it's not we've got the tape
we've got the tape don't let them call
you a conspiracy theorist for quoting
their own words
because that's what they're doing
mike anton the political philosopher and
writer made this point the other day he
said right now it's not just
that
the the democrats are not letting us
point out things that they are doing
it's that the democrats do a thing
and then they tell us that they're doing
the thing
and then they tell us that we're not
allowed to say that they're doing that
thing they're even telling they're
putting it out on on camera on video in
print they're saying defund the police
means defund the police what are you
talking about i never said defund the
police don't you say it if you say that
i said that you're going to be censored
you're going to be suppressed on social
media you're going to be spreading fake
news
it's a conspiracy theory now speaking of
conspiracy theories
you know we have pointed out on this
show especially during this covid era
that the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth is about six to 12
months
it's a lot faster than that now
i think we're looking more like six to
12 days we might be looking at six to
twelve hours there was a conspiracy
theory the other day
and someone brought this up to me and i
thought what what are you talking i
haven't even heard of this
this conspiracy theory said the us has
funded
bio labs in ukraine
and these bio labs may have pla be
playing some role in the russian
invasion of ukraine
so i i said i haven't even heard of this
i google it
immediately snopes fact checker fake
news there's totally fake news ignore
this pay no attention the man behind the
curtain okay then just yesterday i see a
headline
chinese propaganda
pushes false crazy conspiracy theory
about u.s funded bio labs in ukraine and
then just hours later the under
secretary of state for political affairs
victoria newland
testifies before the senate and says
well actually yeah maybe
uh maybe we've got those bio labs you're
right
ukraine has a
biological research facilities
which in fact we are now quite concerned
russian troops russian forces
may be seeking to
uh gain control of so we are working
with the ukrainians on how they can
prevent any of those
research materials from falling into the
hands of
russian forces should they approach
so we might have some yeah i don't want
to say bio labs biological
uh edifices
of research
um and we really don't want the russians
to get them
well hold up so now what the government
with the us government is admitting is
yes okay we've been funding these labs
and they're for biological research but
it's only to stop diseases this was the
fouchy excuse no we're not we're not
doing any gain of function research
we're not making new diseases we're just
we're just we're not certainly not doing
bio weapons we're just sort of you know
we're trying to stop
disease
okay well if that's the case
then why are you so worried about it
falling into russian hands if these are
just purely totally above board
biological research facilities then
what's the big deal if the russians get
their hands on them
because maybe there's a little bit more
going on at these labs maybe just like
with fauci just like with we're not
doing any kind of function research
we're not we have no connection to the
wuhan institute of virology we have not
in any way funded oh whoopsy daisy we
totally did we funded gain and function
at the
institute uh never mind look over there
pay no attention to the man behind the
green curtain guys
we're a little over 24 hours away from
the premiere of our next big hit the
hyperions the film is exactly what
entertainment in hollywood is missing
these days it's not woke it has zero
agenda it could not care less about your
pronouns when it comes to entertainment
just having fun is really what matters
check out this trailer
good day hyperion club members
[Music]
[Applause]
we've come for one thing
our titan badges this titan badge can
grant an individual superhuman power
perhaps it's time for someone else to
take on the responsibility
on my way
[Music]
[Applause]
she's trying to destroy me
you gotta check out the movie i
absolutely love it i watched it on
saturday this is a terrific movie we're
going to be streaming this film once
on march 10th and that's it we're going
to be streaming it for everyone to see
on youtube so be sure to head on over to
the dailywire youtube channel set a
reminder for the live showing after that
you've got to be a member to get in on
the action go to dailywire.com subscribe
so you don't miss any more of the
growing cache of content we have to
offer we'll be right back with a lot
more
welcome back to the show
conspiracy theory yesterday morning
there was a conspiracy theory that the
united states has funded bio labs in
ukraine and this has something to do
with the war going on right now that was
a crazy radical russian propaganda
chinese propaganda terrible conspiracy
theory and then the under secretary of
state admitted that it's true
in testimony before the u.s senate
so what are these labs
there's three
theories here the russians say these
labs are working on biological weapons
and that there are lots of these labs
throughout former soviet territory and
so it's in the
national security interest of the
russian federation to go in and take
control of these labs
china says that the united states has
not only a handful of labs in ukraine
they've actually got 336 bio labs that
they're funding in 36 different
countries and the united states says
okay sure so maybe we've provided some
funding to these labs in ukraine but
they're not working on bio weapons at
all they're merely working to destroy
potential pathogens
who do i believe here
i don't believe the united states
i hate i hate that i wish i could
believe the official lines of my own
country but i can't because they lied to
us about this exact same issue
in wuhan china
they lied to us about this exact same
issue with regard to gain of function
research so the u.s has absolutely no
credibility on this issue i don't
believe that
are do we have 336 bio labs in 36
countries i don't know i don't maybe we
do maybe we don't
i
i don't think the chinese have our best
interests at heart i don't think they're
the most honest people but still
maybe they're telling the truth the
russians say we're working on biological
weapons and there are a lot of these
there's some in georgia and other parts
of ex-soviet territory maybe that's true
maybe it's not i don't know i don't know
who to believe i really don't believe
any of these players
and i'm not sure who is closest to the
truth the big takeaway though
this is this is the biggest takeaway of
all is that this war
just got a lot more dangerous or rather
i suppose the war has always been this
dangerous and the public only now found
out about it
not only are we talking about the first
major war between civilized countries in
my lifetime
not only are we talking about a former
superpower with nuclear weapons
threatening to use those weapons now
we've got biological weapons entering
into the chat
because when the united states says oh
this is nothing it's totally wholesome
it's above board we're just killing
pathogens well if that were the case i
don't think we would be so worried about
these labs falling into russian hands
i think probably
the state department is worried because
they know that there's some weird stuff
going on at these labs and they don't
want incriminating evidence or potential
weapons falling into the hands of the
russians regardless of who's telling the
truth regardless of what's actually
going on at these labs this war
is even more dangerous than people
previously realized
speaking of conspiracy theories in our
public health system
you know that the vaccines the covid
vaccines are one
not one hundred percent safe they are
one thousand percent safe if you even
raise the prospect of there possibly
being the slight chance that you get a
vaccine injury from these vaccines
you're a crazy anti-vaxxer
tinfoil hat rube idiot conspiracy
theorist
and that is why
the department of health and human
services is encouraging people to enroll
in their after vaccine health checker
they want to check up on your health
after you get the vaccines because of
how totally 100 safe the vaccines are
right they just they want affirmation
they just all they want is they they
message you they say you're you're
feeling okay or you have you collapsed
or anything is your heart three times
its size like like the grinch you know
on christmas or
no no good i'm glad we've been affirmed
in our claims what does hhs say well the
assistant secretary for health who is a
fella who thinks he's a gal by the name
of dr robert levine says after getting
your coven 19 booster shot be sure to
use v-safe
to get your personalized and
confidential text message check-ins
about how you feel
but of course you feel great because of
how totally safe the vaccines are
so this is just really just a little
redundant isn't it this information
helps the cdc monitor the safety of
covet 19 vaccines in near real time says
the cdc
i don't know why they have to monitor it
though because it's so totally safe
during the first week after each
vaccination vsaf will send you a text
message each day to ask how you're
feeling after that you will receive
occasional health check-ins depending on
your answers someone from the cdc may
call to get more information your
personal information in v-safe is
protected so it's safe and private
you can opt out anytime i guess the only
reason why you wouldn't be able to
respond to these text message check-ins
is uh if you had a blood clot or your
heart swelled up and exploded or you got
a nerve nerve damage none of which
happened by the way
because of how totally safe
these vaccines are so obviously
hhs is admitting here
that well
they're not 100 safe okay they may be
very safe but it's not 100 and they're
clearly a little bit worried and they
want to collect these data and you know
they're never going to release these
data they're going to try to suppress
these data as long as they possibly can
but they want to know what's going on
and they're going to monitor it and
they'll tell you just as much truth as
they think that you can hear while still
doing what they want
they'll yeah sure they'll
they'll give you a little bit of
information but only the information
that will still impel you to do what
they want these people who have no more
credibility
information is power here we are living
in the information age this is the age
of the internet this has been true long
before the internet actually with the
rise of the modern state you see the
rise of the social sciences to provide
statistics which comes from the word
statist statistics to feed that modern
state
because information is power and so
our government our administrative
agencies are taking all this information
in
and even in their very collection of it
they are tacitly acknowledging
that they lied to us
about safety potentially about efficacy
but they're not they're not even going
to tell us that this might be why the
florida surgeon general
dr joseph ladapo is now recommending
that children
not get the covet vaccine
ladapo said the florida department of
health is going to be the first state to
officially recommend against the
covin-19 vaccines for healthy children
this makes sense the
children face a very low risk of
hospitalization or death from covid the
vaccines are an experimental drug that's
just by definition they're very recently
created drugs there's no really
long-term studies on their effects and
so he says you know for these kids who
don't face a real risk of it
just uh avoid the vaccines the white
house is furious
florida surgeon general says that
healthy children
shouldn't get the cova vaccine
is that a good policy
uh absolutely not uh let me just note
that we know the science we know the
data and what works
and what is the most what the most
effective steps are in protecting people
of a range of ages from
hospitalization and even death the fda
and cdc have already weighed in in the
safety on the safety and efficacy of
covid19 vaccines for those five and
older the recommendations are vetted
transparently through a process
for
with a purpose so that parents can have
confidence after consulting with their
pediatricians or doctors if they would
like about the safety but we also know
through the data that unvaccinated
teenagers are three times as likely to
they to be hospitalized if they get
coveted than vaccinated teenagers so
it's deeply disturbing that there are
politicians peddling conspiracy theories
out there and casting doubt on
vaccinations when it is our best tool
against the virus and the best tool to
prevent even teenagers from being
hospitalized
this this surgeon general
dr joseph ladapo he's just a conspiracy
theorist politician
unlike dr fauci who has actually spread
conspiracy theories and who has worked
for the government gotten the highest
federal salary for 40 years no he's not
a politician how dare you accuse dr
fauci of being a politician he's just a
good old-fashioned scientist who pursues
the truth he represents science itself
he he that man is the incarnation of
science
but this doctor who's got a way better
record than dr fauci ever does this
doctor in florida
he is a crazy conspiracy theorist
politician
he should wear that as a badge of honor
because these days conspiracy theorist
is probably the
the
most honorable title you could be given
it means that
you're about to be proven completely
correct in about i don't know five or
six hours now
notice too the way she twists his words
dr ladapo says that he's recommending
against the covid vaccine for healthy
kids
and then
gensake using some statistics that may
or may not be true i don't know but
let's just say they are true she says
teenagers who are vaccinated
face a much lower risk of
hospitalization
but dr ladapa didn't say all teenagers
whenever there have there have been
relatively few teenage deaths from coven
19 and whenever there is a teenage death
you see major headlines everywhere as
part of the liberal establishment's push
to get us all to take the fouchy algae
and they say healthy teenager
healthy teenager healthy child dies of
covet 19 and inevitably you look into
the so-called healthy young person and
the healthy young person is 400 pounds
and has
five comorbidities and has like six
kinds of diabetes i don't mean to make a
joke about this but i'm pointing out the
ab absolute dishonesty
that
the the liberal establishment is pushing
on us here and and to in order to
convince
actual healthy young people to get a
vaccine that it is probably not in their
interest to get at least according to
the surgeon general of florida and
according to a lot of other people who
have a way better record than dr fauci
and the liberal establishment speaking
of ways to harm your children
if your kid's got some free time coming
up this summer there is a new summer
camp
that your child can go to chris ruffo
the the crt guy has just uh found this
little gem
it's a it's a camp
for your child to learn about sex ed and
that's good we've all been told you need
comprehensive sex ed health education
that's just responsible that's just
following the science there's nothing
radical about that
it's just the right responsible thing to
do
it's called sexy sex ed
it is
a quote a workshop series that compels
teenagers and people of all ages to
openly discuss personal and political
consent
sexual safety and anatomy
i love this word compels
it's not impels which would be to you
know push along it's not uh persuades or
encourages no it's compels they're gonna
force these kids and people of all ages
to openly discuss personal and political
consent sexual safety and anatomy okay
so what are some of the workshops we've
got oh i just downloaded it from the
sexy sex ed website
we've got um
okay the very first workshop this is on
july 6th
it's a tuesday mark your calendar is sex
with me a self-pleasure workshop
participants will explore personal views
on self-pleasure as well as learn
techniques
yeah
to make the most out of their yeah i'm
not you i'm gonna this is a family show
some kids listen to this i'm gonna clean
up some of the language here uh to make
the most out of
what woody allen called sex with someone
you love
this workshop will include discussion
games
and some hands-on practice
now they they add here at the end on
hands so maybe that's just like a joke
and a pun in you
you just
you do some creepy stuff to your own
hand i don't know i don't want to know
gender diversity that one's on tuesday
that's the following week tuesday the
13th so your child can learn about how
if he wants to chop off his genitals and
mutilate his body he can pretend to be
another type of sex
uh let's talk about sex sexy trans sexa
there's that self-managed abortion
that's good that's that's what
nine-year-olds and ten-year-olds should
learn about right
uh then there's sex on drugs you gotta
learn about sex on drugs
i don't know if that's are they
discouraging i assume they're
encouraging that
uh and then there's a closing ceremony
there's lots of other creepy stuff in
there too but
you get the picture and so you're
reading that you think gosh that's
that kind of goes beyond just science
you know that seems not just like you're
presenting relevant responsible
scientific information to your child
that seems to be ideological that seems
to have a political cultural even
spiritual
dimension to it
right because you're discussing moral
issues here and then
the real cherry on top of this sunday is
you look into who runs
this sexy summer camp totally just
responsible scientific information for
people of all ages and the person who
runs it is a self-described
witch
yes we have
uh taney
taney is
a
a
femme femme fat queer magical pleasure
worker
educator and artist she was raised in
rural kentucky by a host of witchy women
alongside sisters and cousins
a coven like mountain matriarchy if you
will her craft tools are candles
crystals oils plants music sex toys
tarot cards the moon and the instincts
of a triple water sign she started the
appalachian sex ed collective called
sexy sex ed
with over a decade of rural organizing
practice toward healing abolition and
liberation she fantasizes about a whole
other world
tanya lives
high on a kentucky mountain top with
lots of plants a steamy hot tub and
several furry familiars
for those who are not familiar with the
storm familiars that's
like the cat
that witches will use
to carry out their schemes that's that's
actually what that word means that's
what she's referring to you can join her
coven over at patreon
capitalism always wins in the end right
even for the witches hey donate to my
patreon hey go over to my gofundme so
this is how
tanya taney describes her
camp deal with yourself explore your own
body masturbation is really healthy and
i recommend it to people of all ages
all ages as soon as my nephews could
talk they were doing that that's what
they were doing kids touch themselves
kids start to ask questions and we teach
them the language for their bodies right
that's your nose touch your nose show
aunt tea you can touch your nose but my
sister's not saying that when they're
tugging at their penis right but
it feels good right we have to learn
ways to talk to young people about this
so that they know how to explore their
body consensually so that it's not in
public right we don't want people
exploring their bodies in public that's
not consensual but exploring your body
at any age grandmas grandpas all of us
need to be exploring
we need to be exploring all of all of
our bodies whether you're a
three-year-old and well don't worry
we'll teach you how to do it
three-year-old just like my nephews
three-year-old maybe some grandparents
too that's what we've got to do i'm a
witchy woman i'm literally telling you
i'm a witch right now i do witchcraft
i'm a part of the witch religion and so
send your kids to me for summer camp
and what do what do the liberals do they
kind of laugh about this they say oh
oh she's a witchy woman you're like
you're like hillary you're a nat you're
a nasty woman
well-behaved women seldom make history
one time i was interviewing uh greg
jarrett the fox news journalist about a
new book that he was doing
and it was it was called witch hunt i
think that was the title of the book
that was at least the theme of the book
that donald trump was subject to a witch
hunt and he made this point on the air
he said the thing about witch hunts
michael is that there's no such thing as
witches and i just i let him go on and
pitch the book and he's a nice guy and
he's a good journalist
but that point really stuck with me
because
he's wrong he's totally wrong this might
be one of my less popular views but it
happens to be correct
witches are totally real they're
obviously real
every culture throughout all of history
has believed in witches there are people
right now who call themselves witches
one of the fastest growing cults in
america is the wicca cult what is wicca
wicca is just witchcraft by its own
definition that's what it is
this woman when people tell you who they
are
believe them
now what does that mean does that mean
that they fly around on broomsticks
probably not
not i'm not gonna say it's a zero
percent chance but probably they don't
have green skin and pointy hats and fly
around on broomsticks but they do lots
of weird occult rituals and there is
more
in heaven and earth horatio that is
dreamt of in our philosophy
this workshop is the perfect example of
this of what we talk about frankly a lot
on this show
the way that sex ed is
presented or is sold to the public when
people want to put it in schools and
other community groups is they say look
this is just science it's just science
it's just this is how the body works and
there's no moral aspect or spiritual
aspect or anything like that
well then how come it's always the
witches doing it you know how come it's
all
when you look into
vice when you look into
lots of
nasty things in our culture whether it's
this creep trying to groom children or
whether it's
porn or whether it's drug culture or
whether it's all the kind of seedy
underbelly of society
you'll notice that it's got a lot of
symbolism to it
there's always a kind of
devilish symbolism to it
you see it throughout all of these
things a lot you'll notice that people
who are really into this stuff they
embrace kind of weird symbolism they
embrace weird identities they call
themselves witches why is that is that
just like a funny weird eccentric quirk
or is there maybe a connection here is
there maybe a connection between the
metaphysical world and the physical
world
is it may be the case that all politics
is not merely cultural but actually at
bottom theological and all human
conflict maybe is theological one thing
i know at the political level
is
that stuff is not going to play in
peoria okay and what we should do is
play those commercials again and again
and again and say this is what these
creeps want to do to your kids that's
what won glenn juncken the race in
virginia to become governor of virginia
he said they want to brainwash your kids
into this crazy stuff dr oz just came
out dr oz is the tv show host who's
running for senate pennsylvania he says
he will be a bold voice in the senate a
proud champion for the pro-life movement
he'll never shy away from sharing his
pro-life beliefs even as pro-abortion
advocates in medicine the media and big
check try to silence me oh good i'm glad
we've got a pro-life candidate there
except just a few months ago dr oz was
was talking about how crazy the
pro-lifers are and how he's so worried
that abortion is going to be made
illegal now what are your thoughts on
alabama and these anti-abortion laws
that they're passing in alabama well
that they've passed is that healthy
i'm i'm really worried about it i tell
you i i've taken care of a lot of women
who've had issues around childbirth the
problem with the law is it stands now i
think i think they'll always really only
pass to generate a supreme court
challenge
but most women don't know they're
pregnant it's only it's two weeks past
your last period when you'll when you
have to decide by what yeah i have
people on the show all the time who
never know they were pregnant even when
they were delivering 50 of women don't
know they're pregnant when they're
pregnant jesus so you're asking women to
decide almost instantaneously if they're
pregnant or not and they it's also
banned in case of incest and rape and so
i i don't quite get it as a doctor and
the other thing is this whole thing
about heartbeating
i mean they're electrical
changes at six weeks but the heart's not
beating
if you if you were if you were to say
starting from when we can hear the heart
like when the heart's really doing
something that'll be different
that's not six weeks though right so if
you can define life by a beating heart
then make it a beating heart not little
electrical changes in this in a cell
that's not that no one would hear would
think about as a heart just it's just
crazy you know these these heartbeat
laws not even a heart that baby he's not
even really a baby i'm really concerned
i'm really nervous about these pro-life
laws
oh i thought you were a tireless
advocate of pro-life causes i thought
you were a tireless advocate of the
unborn who's being silenced by the media
no you're an abortion supporter who has
now changed your views because you want
to win this senate seat so okay look
maybe he just was uneducated on the
issue now he's better educated i don't
know i don't really care i don't care
about dr oz i do care about the senate
seat but what i really care about is dr
oz is flipping here
because the social issues are winners
for conservatives don't back away from
them folks lean into them right now all
the democrats have is blaming putin for
everything that's all they've got their
own failed policies the best they can do
is say well you know putin is put it's
putin's fault go blame go blame russia
no it's your fault you guys have done
this on the economy on foreign policy
and on the absolute ruination of society
run on those cultural issues and
conservatives will win i'm michael
knowles is the michael noel show see
tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the matte wall show what is a
sexy summer camp for children you
probably don't want to know but you're
going to find out today because this is
the sort of thing happening in our
country also with gas prices rising the
left has decided that actually high gas
prices aren't so bad even in fact
americans like paying higher gas prices
we'll talk about that and the senate
unanimously passes the anti-lynching law
every republican signed on to this
pointless bit of virtue signaling the
buy administration commits billions to
spreading gender equity across the globe
and the guy who runs cpac comes out in
support of leah thomas all that and more
today on the matt wall show